[Música]
bienvenidos a en exclusivo de france 24
nos encontramos en la ciudad de los
ángeles para la novena cumbre de las
américas y precisamente en el marco de
esta cumbre nos hizo un espacio en su
agenda al presidente de panamá
laurentino cortizo presidente
bienvenidos france24 le agradezco
muchísimo por su tiempo buenos días
gracias por entrevista empiezo por
preguntarle en primer lugar esta novena
cumbre de las américas sin tres actores
clave
que no fueron invitados le habló de cuba
por supuesto de venezuela y de nicaragua
cuál es su posición al respecto
o sea yo entiendo perfectamente bien
el tema de la carta democrática carta
democrática si mal no recuerdo se firmó
no sé si va a firmar en quebec
es un documento que habla mucho del
fortalecimiento institucional y la
democracia y la importancia los respeto
a los derechos humanos
y en ese sentido el anfitrión es estados
unidos y decidió excluir a tres países
de las américas
personalmente mi posición yo no lo
hubiese excluido
porque prefiero en el caso particular
mío
no tenerlos tan distanciados tenerlo más
cerca
y buscarte a través de la diplomacia sé
que se ha hecho mucho en ese tema
precisamente con cuba venezuela
nicaragua se ha trabajado diferentes
frentes con el tema diplomático
pero siempre al final de todo conflicto
después a nosotros nos sentemos
realmente nos sentimos hablar
frente a frente de verdad siento que la
salida la mejor salida es la diplomática
o sea la inclusión de estos tres países
probablemente hubiese sido importante en
esta esta cumbre y no excluirlos y
someter a otros países a las situaciones
que sabemos que estamos ahora mismo el
caso por ejemplo méxico y otros países
que yo hubiese preferido que estuviesen
aquí
presidente y precisamente usted habla
entonces del camino diplomático pero ya
se ha intentado conversar de muchas
maneras entre la oposición y se han
llevado a cabo distintas
conversaciones con mediación de varios
países cuál es entonces en su opinión la
salida para venezuela en este caso en el
tema de venezuela cuando dice se han
realizado y en efecto si se ha realizado
una serie de reuniones entre comillas
con la oposición
la pregunta mía es existen venezuela una
oposición única consolidada y luego la
respuesta no mientras aún exista
ahí se demuestra
una debilidad entonces lo primero que
debe hacer venezuela es y yo conozco
venezuela tengo muy buenos amigos
venezuela desde que estuve en la
universidad en eeuu es que la oposición
se consolide con un proyecto de país
porque al final surgen muchas veces las
personalidades
el famoso kim quien va a liderizar la
oposición en venezuela
entonces mientras esa oposición esté así
fraccionada de
no es tan fácil
un diálogo fructífero no está fácil
entonces
comienza por ese paso no una oposición
un poco más fuerte más unificada y en
este momento usted anteriormente había
reconocido al presidente juan guaidó
como el presidente legítimo
en este momento quién es para usted la
figura fuerte de la oposición no es un
tema que debe resolver venezuela ellos
tienen que tomar esa decisión y tienen
que tomarla
mirando
muy profundamente cada uno de ellos la
importancia de la unidad
venezuela es un gran país
vuelvo y repito lo conocí antes de
chávez
estuvo un par de oportunidades una
oportunidad cuando el gobierno de chaves
pero antes ya ellos fui muchas veces a
venezuela
es un gran país y de gente muy buena y
un país económicamente fuerte para que
estén las situaciones que está ahora
mismo entonces lo que nosotros como
panamá pudiésemos hacer
para
unir ambas partes
nosotros somos un puente no solamente el
puente de las américas en el tema de
comercio y logística pero también
buscamos la paz en la región mientras
tengamos nuestros países y nuestra
región
se nos hace difícil enfrentar otros
grandes problemas que tenemos nosotros
en este momento
precisamente la migración
como precisamente la migración la
migración al final de cuentas y nosotros
acá vamos a tener hace en abril
una reunión grande de ministro de
relaciones exteriores de la región
directores de instituciones migratorias
ministros de seguridad estuvo el
secretario de estado blink en mallorca
tuvo también por parte de eeuu el tema
migratorio no está afectando a todos en
un año normal en panamá estaban entrando
pasando por una selva y nos pita el
tapón de darién y nos ha sido mucho
migrando alrededor de 10.000 personas
el año pasado pasaron un poco más de 140
mil
y en este momento y tengo las cifras
acaban de ser abiertos los días el
ministro de seguridad alrededor de banja
rededor de 39 y personas la mayoría
venezuela un poco haití y menos cuba
pero esos tres países venezuela pero por
lejos de los 38 mil 39 mil que van
tiene el 60 a 70 por ciento entonces ahí
tienes un tema que no es nada más de un
país es un tema que tenemos que
enfrentarlo
muchos países en la región porque
tienes a corto plazo algunas medidas que
se pueden tomar por ejemplo para ese
flujo controlado de país en país porque
ellos vienen esto tú estás familia
porque hay familia que viene emigrando
vienen de diferentes países pasan por
colombia
llega a panamá
en condiciones muy complicadas desde el
punto de vista de salud en temas el
primer país que los atiende a ellos es
panamá y le hace todas las medidas
biométrica todo lo que se necesita pero
no no es solamente verlo desde el punto
vista de un país de él pero de repente
de la región sino cuáles son las raíces
por la cual esas personas toman la
decisión familias con niños chiquitos la
decisión de abandonar su tierra su
patria para arriesgar sus vidas
qué es lo que está pasando en las las
raíces de ese movimiento que se ha
incrementado muchísimo entonces ahí
tenemos que ver como región
eeuu tiene que estar bien claro en esto
o sea esto es mucho más que
declaraciones estos son hechos fax que
vamos a hacer para que en esos países
donde hay esa es ese movimiento
migratorio
venezuela el caso por ejemplo de haití
qué oportunidades hay de trabajo para
que se queden de oportunidades de
trabajo hay para que se queden
e infraestructuras públicas podemos
nosotros o sea como región incluyendo
eeuu que le conviene que se queden
porque al final hacia dónde va esto esa
familia todas esas personas van hacia
eeuu entonces por ejemplo el tema de la
mujer la mujer rural el
microemprendimiento
ese tipo de trabajo que se tiene que
concretar las acciones tienen que ser
concretas por ejemplo yo estoy aquí en
esta cumbre
este mi primera cumbre durante llegar
aquí también me gusta leer
he leído muchos discursos
he leído comunicado he visto fotos
pero al final
lo decía muy al panameño cual en la
concreta
al final que es lo que va a salir de
esta cumbre es más al final que lo que
ha salido de la otra cumbre
qué es lo que han salido de otras
cumbres
entonces ahí es donde tenemos que pasar
de las palabras
y en efecto nosotros después de la
reunión ministerial que tuvimos hace dos
meses atrás en abril en panamá ya
conforman grupos de trabajo casualmente
para ver los problemas las raíces o las
raíces del problema violencia mis
ministros como anfitriones traten de que
esta reunión de una vez por todas no
solamente presente o sea un
procedimiento de uso mucho o sea que
observé lo que está pasando que analice
lo que está pasando pero que recomiende
para tomar entonces acciones porque lo
contrario nos vamos a quedar con las
mismas cosas una gran cantidad de
papeles mucho discurso
la acción
nada de acción entonces es el producto
por ejemplo de esta cumbre
qué más resulta de esta cumbre está
cumbre va a girar alrededor
del tema migratorio
y qué pasó con el tema de la
recuperación
o pandemia y las consecuencias que ya
estamos viviendo de la invasión de rusia
ucrania
esos son los temas que tenemos nosotros
que hablar
llegar a acuerdos y ejecutarlos
presidente precisamente aprovecho que
usted está diciendo eso que quedan
muchas veces en declaraciones en la
declaración final de cada una de estas
cumbres qué acciones concretas pueden
por ejemplo portar panamá para atender
este tema de la migración pero nosotros
ya lo estamos haciendo
y hemos sido reconocidos también
internacionalmente por el trabajo que he
estado haciendo panamá
con un presupuesto muy limitado
nosotros damos
utilizando recursos para atender ese
flujo migratorio que ha sido
incrementándose una manera bueno se le
acabó dar cifra de 10.000 a 140.000 ya
esos recursos que hemos estado usando
panamá para atender el tema salud
vuelvo y repito primer país que los
atiende
porque por donde van pasando es
básicamente eso pasando por otros países
nosotros tenemos albergues les tenemos
comida les tenemos el tema de salud o
sea los atendemos se vacunan contra kobe
o sea
lo estamos atendiendo ese es un
aporte directo de los panameños
hacia el tema de esa migración irregular
yo quisiera preguntar por ejemplo otros
países
incluyendo eeuu yo entiendo el problema
que tiene eeuu en frontera
con médico
pero es que eso se puede atender antes
no cuando llegan allá si van a llegar
pero no la cantidad que están llegando
entonces desde el punto de vista de eeuu
si los han que tienen un dolor de cabeza
enorme
saben perfectamente bien que tiene
elecciones de noviembre
entonces lo que es importante
independientemente de lo de la gran
cantidad de problema que tiene eeuu y
que tenemos todos los países
busquemos la forma de que se queden
acciones concretas para ver cómo vamos
minimizando ese flujo que se ha
incrementado enormemente
necesitan panamá y colombia por ejemplo
que comparten esta frontera frontera del
tapón del darién más fondos desde eeuu
para atender este problema no tengo
ninguna duda es la respuesta a esa
pregunta absolutamente ninguna duda
ambos países
colombia panamá que por cierto ambos
gobiernos estoy hablando del gobierno
saliente del presidente duque y mi
administración hemos realizado ambas
administraciones trabajo sumamente bien
coordinado
yo tengo que reconocer esto aquí en esta
entrevista mi relación como presidente
de panamá y el presidente de colombia ha
sido una relación
frente a frente o sea nosotros hemos
trabajado esta relación como países
vecinos de una manera yo lo puedo decir
correcta y correcta en diferentes
aspectos desde el punto de vista
comercial del punto de vista por ejemplo
delincuencia del crimen organizado o sea
la relación que hay entre ambos países
ha sido importante pero si se requieren
recursos especialmente de eeuu para
apoyar a ambos países panamá con esa
frontera
enorme inhóspita de una selva húmeda
tropical
donde están falleciendo
migrantes se requieren recursos por
supuesto que se requiere recurso
y esos son los temas donde al final
uno se reúne con eeuu pero que al final
lo que uno quiere es el pero
después lo que hemos hablado después de
todo este tema que no está observando
cómo aumenta la migración en los
análisis que se hace en todas estas
reuniones las recomendaciones y las
acciones
esto es ir tomando acciones concretas
y con qué gobierno en colaborar usted
podría mantener estas acciones concretas
de este plan de trabajo conjunto
teniendo en cuenta que tenemos
elecciones del próximo mente hablando
entre el petro y hernández
con el que ustedes decidan
para más un buen vecino
y mientras yo sea presidente mis
relaciones con colombia o cualquier otro
país incluyendo eeuu y dos relaciones
directas
hay veces que coincidimos y otras veces
que no coincidimos
pero
las veces que tenga que hablar
y decirle alguna cosa que no me gusta
cualquiera de los dos candidatos se lo
voy a decir con respeto presidente
volviendo al tema de eeuu que también
nos dice que va a trabajar con cualquier
gobierno que se presente eventualmente
pero volviendo al tema específicamente
el tratado de libre comercio que se
pidió una renegociación
y como estas discusiones también
entiendo con el secretario de antony
blinken en que está esto en este momento
en efecto nosotros no estamos hablando
panamá no está hablando o la solicitud
formal que hizo panamá a la oficina
comercial de eeuu es tirar y a la
secretaria de agricultura no es la
negociación d
ese tlc
si no es la revisión de cuatro productos
que son sensitivos para panamá son los
productos vinculado por ejemplo arroz
las carnes productos lácteos algunos
productos lácteos
y en ese sentido
la canciller de panamá tiene la próxima
semana una reunión casualmente con la
oficina comercial de los eeuu y bestial
para ver cómo nos podemos sentar
y
buscar solución porque nosotros
requerimos solución en nuestra balanza
comercial con eeuu es
sumamente favorable pero extremadamente
favorable a los eeuu y para nosotros el
sector agropecuario especialmente esos
cuatro productos es vital es fundamental
para la paz social
hay esas cuatro actividades representan
una generación de empleo muy importante
para el país
entonces yo espero que eeuu se siente
con nosotros que conversemos y que
busque una manera de llegar a
entendimiento positivo para panamá y
eeuu que le interese a eeuu
entonces como vecino américa latina mi
recomendación a eeuu
más hacia américa latina miren más hacia
américa latina
no es un reemplazo total del acuerdo
sino solamente cuatro puntos en especie
cuatro puntos y cuatro productos en
específico
y qué hay de las manos y acciones que
empezó el expresidente varela con china
sigue siendo estados unidos el principal
socio comercial o puede haber un
acercamiento más estados unidos nuestro
principal socio comercial uno
el nuestro principal socio estratégico 2
el primer usuario del canal
sheen es el segundo usuario del canal en
este momento
nosotros vamos a reiniciar
esas negociaciones
con china
ese proceso ya inició con la
administración pasada de panamá
ese proceso tiene que
realizarse
más hacia el tema agropecuario
el punto de vista de panamá
e independientemente de las asimetrías
estamos hablando de una economía
sumamente
fuerte segunda más potente del mundo con
panamá pero eso no significa que porque
panamá ser chico
nosotros no hemos estado con potencias
como eeuu negociar de tú a tú que
nosotros con china también vamos a
negociar de tú a tú
bajo la condición de
qué mayúscula negrita y subraya respeto
así como le exigimos a otros países por
muy grande que sea cuando se sienten con
panamá nos sentamos a conversar tiene
que existir en el medio en la mesa ese
letrero invisible que diga respeto
y así es que estamos nosotros preparados
a negociar a seguir negociando con
chinas chinas para nosotros es
importante
es un socio también importante de vuelvo
y repito es un usuario
importantísimo del canal y queremos
avanzar con esa negociación
presiento usted estaba más ya tres años
de su mandato
estamos próximos a cumplirlos le tocó
una situación inédita para todos los
matices del mundo que es la pandemia
alcohol y 19 cualquier oeste que fue su
mayor acierto en atender esta pandemia y
su mayoría roja en el tema de aciertos
sin duda alguna
fue alinear los equipos de gobierno
o sea las instituciones vinculadas al
tema salud que tuviesen bien alineada
qué es una palabra que usó muchos de los
usuarios tres veces en esta entrevista y
la palabra disciplina
equipos bien alineado disciplinado
pudimos nosotros avanzar y enfrentar
la pandemia
con el mismo método que te acabo de
mencionar el equipo de salud un equipo
interinstitucional
observando
analizando y me recomendaban todos los
lunes recibía por escrito las
recomendaciones que tenía que tomar
obviamente serán los momentos más
difíciles que tuve que tomar decisiones
muy duras por ejemplo una cuarentena
estricta para panamá fue muy estricta
porque no nos quedaba otra
cuando yo recibió un 16 de marzo del
2020 un informe de expertos de salud
que me decíamos que no teníamos
175 unidad de cuidado intensivo para
covite
y que en los próximos 5 a 8 meses sigue
a matar
y vamos a tener alrededor de 120.000
casos positivos y que en el peor de los
casos necesitamos más de 5.900 unidades
presentes y en el mejor alrededor de
1900 unidades cuya intensivos y yo lo
que le diera que me decía solamente
tenemos 175 unidades couldn't han sido o
sea ese momento para mí fue el momento
más duro
porque por la mente mía pasaron muchas
cosas por ejemplo
que ese tema sea difícil y pasó en otros
países
el tema de cadáveres de familiares que
tenían que sacar a las calles porque no
podían tener en sus casas o sea eso para
mí era
inaceptable entonces nosotros hicimos lo
que teníamos que hacer para poder tener
suficientes unidades de cuidado
intensivo
creo que en ese momento teníamos 8 por
cada 100.000 no recuerdo la cifra y lo
queríamos llevar a 20 por cada 100.000
personas entonces en eso estuvimos
trabajando pero la organización
porque lo que decíamos no queremos que
el sistema de salud con eso no puede
pasar en este país y por otro lado
actuamos muy rápido cuando actuamos
yo no comienza a tomar decisiones
porque se me ocurría tomar decisiones si
no el equipo equipo especializado
doctores epidemiólogo ellos eran los que
estaban tomás que tomaban
recomendaciones entonces
en un momento dado experto en vacunas
doctores
los reunimos a tiempo
y ahí se decide
en su recomendación y tome la
recomendación era acepté queríamos irnos
por una vacuna
países y astrazéneca y eso se hizo con
mucho tiempo y nos permitirá a panamá
poder negociar y adquirir
suficientes vacunas
pero suficiente para toda la población
que hoy en día nosotros tenemos el 75 de
la población vacunada con el cuarto
refuerzo
tenemos vacunas para toda la población
imagen inclusive nosotros hemos donado
otros países en alguna
desacierto
yo no sé
hay mucho desacierto o sea la silla la
silla presidencial
no toma decisiones
uno quisiera que la decisión que uno
tome sea 100%
aprobada que no es así en el mejor de
los casos 50 50 50 por ciento cincuenta
por ciento o sea no es fácil tomar
decisiones por ejemplo tomar una
decisión
de una cuarentena rígida con un toque de
queda fuerte
con 10 días específicos para mujeres y
para hombres con horas específicos de
acuerdo a las cédulas para hombres para
mujeres
eso no fue fácil
no fue fácil es muy difícil pero bueno
al final
hemos avanzado él
el manejo de la pandemia y panamá ha
sido reconocido por organización
panamericana de la salud
como uno de los países que
lo hizo mejor
solo dice la ope s incluyendo quien
estuvo director de la ope s el doctor
alfaro que ya dejó panamá estará en
guatemala
y el manejo que se hizo
para no estar improvisando
a mí no me gusta improvisar
fue importante regresar otro de los
retos que ha enfrentado durante su
administración y es todo este escándalo
de los papeles de pandora como ha sido
de panamá de bandes respaldará y panamá
como ha sido el trabajo a través de las
investigaciones que ha iniciado su
gobierno fíjate nosotros en el caso
particular me voy un poquito para atrás
porque nos está mencionando los papeles
de panamá y lo de pandora un mes antes
de erp y tome posesión en junio
a nosotros nos pusimos en panamá quedó
en la lista gris del gafi y hemos estado
avanzando de una manera muy importante
el plan de acción en café tiene 15
puntos ya llevamos 8 muy avanzado y 7
parcialmente avanzado o sea que el
avance
de panamá
ha sido sustancial inclusive del punto
de vista interinstitucional que nos
reunimos una vez por semana en muchas de
esas reuniones yo participo
en el tema por ejemplo de los papeles de
panamá
no tanto pandora's luego pl panamá deja
necesite algo
0.26 por ciento de las compañías
offshore
sólo el 0.26 por ciento tanto para mí
el resto está en otras partes del mundo
incluyendo en este país
entonces es el nombre de los papeles de
panamá
luego ya se puso
ya se dijo
pero es incorrecto
los papeles están en otras partes que no
es panamá esas sociedades off-shore en
panamá solamente tienes
0.26 eso fue incorrecto eso fue injusto
el mundo sabe porque no estamos
encargando de hacerlo a nivel de
diferentes países españa francia eeuu
sabe perfectamente bien que ese nombre
fue incorrecto y se lee eso fue injusto
para panamá
vuelvo y repito solo el
0.26 por ciento de esas sociedades
anónimas offshore
están en panamá
0.26 por ciento en otros países que
estoy seguro que lo conoce porque hacer
una semana de semana atrás salió una
lista de países lo que eeuu en cabeza
en esos otros países están la mayoría de
esas sociedades que evaden impuestos y
que lavan dinero
laurentino por eso le agradezco
muchísimo su tiempo para france24 y esta
conversación durante la cumbre de la
configuración
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
especial sigan viendo que las 24